i'll tell you what's not going well out
there is all these different
you know a lot of people have different
pronouns these days i'm him
but um dude i hit on this girl right
and in nashville l.a this is in l.a okay
you got to watch your you got to watch
your steps here in l.a man you don't
know what it is these days
dude she said what did she say she goes
um do you like
men and i was like no i mean i like men
they're cool
i don't like mittens anymore
[Laughter]
women
[Laughter]
he gave it a good old cause try that
dude made an effort man
but yeah hit on this she goes oh cause i
identify as a man she's like would you
ever hook up with a guy and i'm like no
and then i didn't know what to do
anymore yeah because you don't offend
her right she's like i
identify as him he and it was just hot
chick yeah i doubt that
it was playboy yeah a hot dude no dude
hey
is this you coming out right now bro no
dude first of all if i was gay dude i
would be shocked
not me especially after this story we
had a bar
he's like hey bro you want a bear you're
like damn you're sexy
bro so you're hitting on this
transgender and dude
would you hook up with a man and i'm
like no you know maybe
yeah i mean i'd hook up with a man like
if we were like you know maybe it was
like a big storm or something but i'm
hooking up with a man in [ __ ] regular
weather yeah if you get
snowed in you might yeah if i get snowed
in and all the women freeze to death
you know and the guy keeps promising
he's a woman
you know or eventually wants to be one
no and
he has to promise he is but anyway so
now it's just kind of strange i didn't
know what to say to her
say to him say to her it was her [ __ ]
look i looked for the kid
i looked for the adam's apple turnover i
looked for all of it yeah the big hands
oh no she didn't have any of it she was
a woman there was no doubt there was no
doubt
no there's doubt because my pronouns
are him his or the [ __ ] it is you're
pronounced they do you're thick ass your
[ __ ] pronoun
my pronouns just thick your friend is
more than one
us dude i'll tell you what i've never
been hit on a chick and never thought to
myself well i wonder what
her pronouns are which is she's pretty
clear she forced the issue
were you at like uh where where were we
at the coffee place
and it was so uncomfortable you know
what to do so i just my shoe dude and i
had sandals on
so i kept just practicing on the sandal
like you do when you're [ __ ]
three-year-old you know so how'd you
leave it
she left man he left him and his
[ __ ] hot chicks him and the three hot
chicks he was with all left yeah
they got in their hummer and drove off
on that h3
did she or he had big tits yeah she had
two big kids yeah
daddy was looking he was i liked it well
that's what i'm saying this you couldn't
have just
there's a lot of bad science out there
for people trying to get the surgery and
stuff like that
these doctors are good though i'll give
you that man those these dogs
especially in l.a they'll get you you
ever heard the story of brian
when he was uh shooting um which story
well a good story okay the story that
matches this
was this in the la times no this one
there it might be after i tell the story
he was shooting uh the hangover two in
thailand or something
and then the the boys went out you know
there's a lot of ladyboys out there
and he said he said he was in a club and
it's all dark
and he's like making out he goes dude
this jake was so hot make out make it
out
and he goes then she took my hand and
just put it down there and he goes i
felt a big root nut
i go damn what'd you do dude he goes i
don't want to finish i just kept making
up
wrote that look i respect good dude
good dude bro why didn't they write that
in the article that they with the
accusations
yeah man that right there is like what
you don't do that if you're if you're if
you're some kind of like deviant you
[Music]
know